I got nothing
before
[Music]
[Applause]
say no to my
place
[Music]
foreign
tonight yeah
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that flow
video I have been looking forward to
shooting in that location all summer and
it did not disappoint uh big thanks to
ultra POI for sponsoring this video and
giving me an excuse to go out and find
beautiful shooting locations just like
that one if you'd like to grab a set of
those orb POI Pro LED contact POI that
I'm using in this video you can do so by
heading on over to ultrapoi.com and
using the promo code drexfactor with a
zero instead of an O at checkout that'll
get you a discount on your own set of
those POI and it helps out the channel
so everybody wins thank you once again
to ultraport for making these videos
possible thank you speaking of thank
yous I also owe a big thank you to the
Friends of the channel uh big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys pyrotera light toys juggling
calling spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like self by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this here video and of
course special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel That
is uh Johnny Howard Lei machinsky and
Becca backlinen thank you one and all
for your very generous support
um and of course this video would not be
possible without the kind sport of all
of these nice people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible uh thank you one and all for
your support and if you out there
watching are a fan of my videos and
you'd like to help me make more of them
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up you can do
that at the link down in the description
or the card that just popped up
um
I I you there you can get access to a
whole bunch of awesome rewards as well
as be supporting me in my mission to
bring foyer koi spinning and flow Arts
to The Wider world so check that out
please and thank you
um and finally if you would like to
check out any of my other flow videos
I'm going to include a link to a
playlist of them down in the description
as well as up on screen here and of
course the YouTube algorithm thinks
based upon your other viewing choices
that you'll probably also like this top
video listed here too so you might want
to check that out as well thank you all
so much for watching make sure to get
out and flow this weekend and I'll see
you with a new video on Monday
peace